boots have been a real perennial in
fashion because they give a sense of
both toughness and also sexuality so
we've been seeing a lot of boots in
autumn and winter for a while what's new
is now the very high boots tend to be
seen a sexier I mean it's really drawing
your eye right up to the thigh and it's
more expensive it's more of a fashion
statement I think a lot of people are
going to be buying shorter boots and
they'll get sort of some of that boot
magic but maybe not the real $2,000
extreme fetish look in boots
perhaps have basically been out as a
requirement since the 1960's because the
strength of hats was always to show your
social status as much as anything else
and once people women stopped wearing
hats and gloves outside all the time to
make a sort of social class statement
and men stopped wearing hats to work
after that hats became either an
optional fashion thing and of course
they can be quite wonderful for that we
have some really interesting milliner's
both in the US and in England in
particular but it's a definite minority
high fashion thing work becomes a
practical thing you know with global
warming we don't want all of the sun
rays hitting you and so people are
protecting themselves with hats but it's
no longer a de facto requirement to
fashion that you need a hat to go with
every outfit
men have no idea that shoes are among
the first things that women look at of
so many young women who are still
looking for a man that's the one of the
first things they look at and if the
shoes look cheap or uncared-for they
write the guy off so I mean they women
know that men are attracted to high he
also but men don't really realize that
women are really looking at their shoes
genes are probably the single most
significant contribution of American
fashion to sort of world of fashion and
they've been a really central part of
late 20th and early 21st century fashion
even in the 70s that had really
proliferated so you had all kinds of
high fashion jeans sort of i think
that's not going to go away but i think
that it's not necessarily thus the three
hundred dollar jeans that will win out
it's more question of which are the
jeans that the cool kids latch on to
some people really are jeans experts I
mean I'm fascinated by the fact that the
Japanese are so obsessive about genes
that they really know exactly what goes
into a perfect 1950s American Jean and
they're willing to pay hundreds of
dollars for replica and thousands of
dollars for an original but I think most
people are looking for you know
something else in a pair of jeans it's
not necessarily the best pair but maybe
just the pair that's trendy or the pair
that will make their body look best
style is important but the Japanese are
looking at is it made on the same kind
of looms is it a heavier weight I mean
some of the deluxe japanese denim are
much much heavier and the dye process
has done much more carefully to
replicate the kind of indigo dying
there's nothing produced here that has
that kind of workmanship that goes into
it well they've really sort of fetishize
to have the jeans like those jeans from
America from the 1950s we don't make
them like that anymore but that's what
they want